GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING CALLING FOR MEMBERS FOR
THIS GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN
ROOM FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS
PLEASE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND I'D LIKE TO FIRST.
.
WELCOME EVERYBODY BACKED START
OF THE YEAR OF MISTER SPEAKER
HAS APPOINTED ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EDUARDO GARCIA TO FILL THEM.
DEMOCRATIC VACANCY FOR TODAY'S
HEARING ONLY.
A WARM WELCOME BACK TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAN COOLEY.
WHO HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO THE
COMMITTEE AGAIN WELCOME TO ALL
OF THE LAST YEAR'S RETURNING?
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
WE HAVE TWO ITEMS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE
WILL HEAR BILLS AND SIGN AN
ORDER. IN OUR FIRST BILL WILL BE
AB ONE THREE TWO FOUR WILL
BEFORE I GO ANY FARTHER I'D LIKE
TO HAVE.
DIXIE CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
AGUIAR CURRY THEIR ANGER CURRY
HERE WALDRON. BLOOM.
BLOOM HERE COPY HERO KABIRA HERE
COOLEY.
COOLEY HERE EDUARDO GARCIA
GRAYSON THEIR GRAYSON HERE
LACKEY LACKEY HERE VOTE PARA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UM I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON WHO IS. HELPING US OUT
TODAY FOR TO PRESENT.
MISTER ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIOUS
BILL AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO DO OPENING
STATEMENT.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA.
WE KNOW HOW DIVERSE CALIFORNIA
CAN BE AND WE OFTEN HEAR ABOUT
THE UNIQUE AND VERY NEEDS
BETWEEN NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OR COASTAL AND INLAND
COMMUNITIES.
BUT THOSE ARE BUT FOR THOSE OF
US WHO HAVE BEEN.
WHO HAVE SERVED ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE KNOW THOSE
DIFFERENCES EXIST EVEN WITHIN
THE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS THAT
WE ONCE REPRESENTED ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES TO TRANSPORTATION?
AS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS PLANNED
FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
PROGRESS IS OFTEN STYMIED WHEN
THE NEEDS OF ONE COMMUNITY
DIFFER FROM THE NEEDS OF ITS
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY NEITHER SUBREGION
REALIZES ANY BENEFIT AND THE
SAME FAILING INFRASTRUCTURE
WHETHER IT BE TRANSIT OR ROAD
REPAIRS GOES WITHOUT
IMPROVEMENTS FOR ACTUALLY
DECADES.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR SEEKS TO
CHANGE THAT BY GRANTING REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AUTHORITIES AND METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATIONS THE
ABILITY TO ADVANCED IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS BY SUB REGION.
UNDER THIS BILL RT PA'S AND NPOS
WOULD BE ABLE TO EXERCISE THEIR
EXISTING SALES TAX AUTHORITY IN
SPECIFIC PORTIONS OF THEIR
JURISDICTION.
IF APPROVED
BY THE REQUIRED NUMBER OF VOTERS
COMMUNITIES WOULD BE THEN
SHIRRED THAT THE DECISION TO TAX
THEMSELVES WOULD NOT BE IN VAIN.
AS THE REVENUES GENERATED FROM
THE APPROVED SALES TAX WOULD BE
AVAILABLE ONLY TO THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA THANKS THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
RAISING SOME OF THE CONCERNS AND
THE ANALYSIS AND IS COMMITTED TO
WORKING ON THOSE. IF THE BILL'S
FORTUNE UP THE MOVE TO THE
FLOOR.
WITH ME I HAVE MARC WATTS ON
BEHALF OF THE PLASTIC COUNTY
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY.
THANK YOU A I'M SHARING MEMBERS
APPRECIATE BEING HERE TODAY.
.
PLUS FOR COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE A.
AYE I COUNTY SUCH AS PLASTER
HAS
THREE DISTINCT.
GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS HAVE GOT THE
LAKE TAHOE AREA WHICH ALREADY
HAS ITS OWN SPECIAL.
TRANSPORTATION SALES TAX
AUTHORITY TO IN IN AND OF
ITSELF.
AND THEN INTO WITHIN THE RENT
WITHIN THE REST THE COW YOU'VE
GOT THE FOOTHILLS AND.
WHAT I CALL THE FLATLANDS BUT
WOULD IT WITH THE?
STAFF THAT THE AGENCY CALLED
THE SUBURBAN AREAS OF PLASTER
COUNTY.
AND PUTTING IT TOGETHER TWO
THIRDS VOTE MAJORITY PROGRAM
WITH THOSE THREE DIVERSE.
AREAS IS DIFFICULT AT BEST.
WE THINK THIS BILL GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO. OF DEVELOP
DISTRICT THAT MAKE SENSE FOR THE
SUBURBAN AREAS AS WELL AS A
SEPARATE. AT AT AT SOME OTHER
TIME A SEPARATE.
DISTRICT FOR THE FOOTHILLS
WHERE IN THE PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS COULD BE MORE TAILORED
SPECIFICALLY TO THE NEEDS THERE.
AND ALLOW VOTERS TO.
TO BOTH YOU SUPPORT THAT AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THE FUNDS WILL
BE RETAINED SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PROJECTS WITHIN THEIR.
JURISDICTIONS SO ON THAT BASIS
WE SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOHNSON
CLAIMED AFTER THE CITY OF
ENCINITAS ALSO IN SUPPORT.
.
FROM A COASTAL CITY PERSPECTIVE
AND SEEN DIEGO.
BEING PART OF TO THE NORTH
COUNTY TRANSIT AREA THERE'S
PARTS OF THAT TRAIN TO DISTRICT
THAT ARE. DIRECTLY IMPACTED BY
THE COASTAL CORRIDOR TRAINS BUT
CITIES LIKE INSIDIOUS CARLSBAD
AND OTHERS ON THAT OF COURT OR
ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED AND
STRUGGLE WITH THE COSTS OF
DOUBLE TRACKING OR DOING OTHER
TYPES A GRADE SEPARATION TO.
FEEL THE IMPROVETHE FLOW OF
TRAFFIC THROUGH THEIR
COMMUNITIES INTO NEED THIS IS.
EMPLEADO EFFECTED BY THE TRAIN.
HAVING THE ABILITY UNDER
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR FOR COASTAL
CITIES TO COME TOGETHER FOR THAT
SPECIFIC ISSUE THE BILL TO
CREATE A FUNDING MECHANISM.
WE SEE A BENEFIT TO THAT AND
IT'S SOMETHING WE'RE NOT SO SURE
THAT SOME OF THEM REST OF
REMEMBERS IN NORTH COUNTY WOULD
DISAGREE WITH BECAUSE THEY DON'T
THEY ARE DIRECTLY IMPACTED
YESTER USERS OF THE THE TRANSIT
DISTRICT AND THERE'S. ISSUES
THAT ARE APPROPRIATELY MORE
BROADLY FUNDED BUT THOSE CITIES
SPECIFIC ESPECIALLY FOR GRADE
CROSSINGS OTHER THINGS PART
SOMETHING LIKE A CITY VINCE
ESCONDIDO OTHER AREAS WERE
NESTLE CARE ABOUT SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE THINK THIS AYE MAKES
SENSE WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S
SOME.
DIFFICULTIES AND HOW YOU
STRUCTURE THIS BUT WE DO THINK
THE IDEA IS.
MERITORIOUS FOR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU GREAT THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE AND WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
I AM VERY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SO ARE THERE QUESTIONS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
PACING NONE.
AND KOKO HEAD.
I'M SORRY.
MADAM CHAIR I DO HAVE A QUESTION
I JUST FROM.
BASICALLY ONE AT PRETTY MUCH
PUT ON THE RECORD THE
CONVERSATION I HAD WITH MR
GLORIA.
APPRECIATE MR GRAYSON BEING
HERE TODAY TO. TO.
PRESENT THIS BILL BUT.
THE CHALLENGE I HAVE IS THAT
FROM UP FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS SAID WE SHOULD BE
DOING OUR TRANSPORTATION.
.
PLANNING ON A REGIONAL BASIS AND
WE'VE SET UP A WHOLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER FOR THAT
TO HAPPEN BECAUSE WE ONE IS
THERE TO BE FREE FLOW. OF OF
TRAFFIC FROM ONE COUNTY TO THE
OTHER END ON IT IT IS AN EASY
HAVING.
TO WORK WITH YOUR NEIGHBOR
COUNTIES WHO HAVE MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENT VIEW OF THE VIEW OF
THE WORLD BUT THE IDEA IS
REGIONAL PLANNING I'M I'M. I M..
.
I THINK I REALLY THINK THANK THE
TESTIMONY FROM CLASSIC COUNTY
AND ALSO.
FROM ENCINITAS BECAUSE THOSE
THAT THERE WAS AN ARTICULATION
OF A SPECIFIC ISSUE THAT'S LOCAL
AND WHAT I TOLD MR GLORIA IS ON
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT. IS.
IT THERE'S ALWAYS FRICTION
BETWEEN THE URBAN. AYE CENTERS
AND THE MORE RURAL CENTERS AND
THERE'S ALSO FRICTION BETWEEN
POOR COMMUNITIES WHO RELY VERY
HEAVILY MAYBE ON ONE FORM OF
TRANSPORTATION AND THE WEALTHIER
COMMUNITIES IT MAY NOT.
AND I'M I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
SETTING UP A THE POSSIBILITY OF
CHERRY PICKING WHERE YOU WANT TO
BE ABLE TO TO. TO TO WIN A
BALLOT MEASURE AND IT IT
DOESN'T.
IT.
INSTEAD OF SAYING WE WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE U. FIGURING OUT THE
BIG PICTURE AND MEETING
EVERYBODY'S NEEDS IT IT ALLOWS
YOU TO DO AND JUST GET MORE PRO
CABLE AND FOCUS ON THE NEEDS OF
ONLY ONE GROUP OF PEOPLE AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT IT LEAVES OUT AS
A. AS A TRANSPORTATION PLANNER
IT LEAVES OUT THE BIG PICTURE
AND SO WHAT WHAT I TOLD HIM I'M
A NO VOTE TODAY WHEN I TOLD HIM
IS I'M WILLING TO CONSIDER A
REGIONAL APPROACH TO IT WHERE
IT'S GOING TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THAT'S. CREATED REGIONALLY I'M
NOT SURE I'M READY TO MOVE.
CHANGING THE HAVING A POLICY
THAT'S.
REALLY IN CONTRAVENTION OF WHAT
WE'VE SET UP IN TERMS OF
REGIONAL PLANNING SO.
BUT THAT'S NOT THE BILL HERE
TODAY IF THERE'S AN INTEREST IF
YOU HAS AN INTEREST IN DOING
THAT DOWN THE ROAD I'M MORE THAN
MONEY TO TO LOOK AT THAT BUT.
I'M JUST CONCERNED BECAUSE.
RIGHT NOW.
WHEN I LOOK AT MY REGION.
ALL OF THE TRANSPORTATION
NETWORK.
THAT IS PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION IS
FROM SAN JOSE NORTH.
AND AND IN AN INCLUDES A TRAIN
SERVICE AND THEN TO THE SOUTH
IT'S SAN LUIS OBISPO SOUTH.
AND SO GUESS WHO'S RIGHT IN THE
MIDDLE WITH ABSOLUTELY NO NO
SERVICE AND BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ANY JUICE IN THOSE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES WORK
WERE LEFT OUT AND SO THE
REGIONAL APPROACH. IS THE ONLY
WAY WE'RE EVER GOING TO GET
CONNECTED AND SO.
THAT THIS KIND OF FLIES IN
EVERY SO I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
HERE TODAY I AM AS I SAID I'M
WILLING TO LOOK AT IT AND IT. AT
AT LOCALIZED SPECIFIC TO MAYBE
PLASTIC KANTIAN TO SAN DIEGO BUT
I'M JUST NOT WANTING TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER OKAY.
SO MEMBER WALDRON. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
.
HAVING SAT ON THE EARTH COUNTY
TRANSIT BOARD FOR EIGHT YEARS.
WHEN WE FIRST IMPLEMENTED THE
COASTER AND. YOU KNOW SIGNED
THE.
THE THE FINANCING AGREEMENTS
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY GET THAT GOING.
.
ISSUES WITH THE.
ENCINITAS THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
IN THE DOUBLE TRACKING AND ALL
OF THAT. THE DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES AND THEIR YOU KNOW
WILLINGNESS TO WORK ON DOUBLE
TRACKING PLUS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PLUS WORKING WITH. YOU KNOW ALL
THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES TO GET
THOSE THINGS DONE. I DON'T SEE
HOW A REGIONAL TAXING APPROACH
COULD EVEN. BEGIN THE GENERATE
THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WOULD
BE NEEDED TO DO A GRADE
SEPARATION OR SOMETHING. LIKE
THAT SO I MEAN I AGREE. THE
REGIONAL APPROACH WHEN YOU LOOK
AT ALL THE CONNECTIONS YOU NEED
BUS CONNECTIONS YOU NEED ALL
KINDS OF OTHER CONNECTIONS MULTI
MODAL IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO.
.
AND MAKE IT WORK I DON'T SEE HOW
JUST DOING YOU KNOW WANTED TO
CITIES OR EVEN JUST THE COLESLAW
KARA WOULD BE ENOUGH TO GENERATE
EVEN IF THAT'S WHAT YOU WANTED
TO DO.
A FUNDING MECHANISM AND YOU
KNOW.
ONCE AGAIN WE WERE NORTH COUNTY
TRANSIT DISTRICT THERE WAS MUCH
AT ALL METROPOLITAN TRANSIT
BOARD THEN THEY WERE BROUGHT
TOGETHER AS ONE TO DO REGIONAL
BELL THERE BEING SEPARATED BACK
OUT AND SAY THAT IT'S LIKE. YOU
KNOW LET'S MAKE A DECISION HOW
DO WE WANT TO DO IT BECAUSE EVEN
AT THIS HEARING I HAVE ASKED THE
QUESTION WHAT HAPPENS IF WE HAVE
A TAX.
ON THE ON THE BALLOT AND ONLY
ONE PART OF THE AREA DECIDES TO
DO AND WE'RE GOING TO BUILD HALF
A PLAN. AND THEY WERE LIKE WE
DON'T KNOW THAT'S HOW IT'S
PROBABLY GONNA SO I'M LOOKING AT
THIS IS MAYBE A. WAY TO ADDRESS
THAT BUT I STILL DON'T SEE HOW
IT WOULD WORK ON A REGIONAL
APPROACH SO. THAT'S MY CONCERN
WITH IT.
ANY OTHER DISCUSSION.
OKAY.
I NEED A MOTION.
CLINTON RUSHED.
IT'S ALL SECOND THE BILL.
MOVE ALONG.
OKAY.
YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING STATEMENT.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OF
HELPING US OUT TODAY HELP WAS TO
LIE ABSOLUTELY MADAM CHAIR AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORY OF SIMPLY
ASKED WHEN I GO.
THANK YOU.
OKAY WORLD AND TAKE A VOTE DIXIE
PLEASE. A MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR CURRY AYE AYE AGUIAR
CURRY AYE WALDRON. WALDRON NO
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE CABBIE HERO.
COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE EDUARDO GARCIA
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY NOVO PARA.
OKAY WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
UNTIL WE GET ALL OUR MEMBERS
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
WAITING.
THERE.
SO MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT BILL AB
NINE SIXTY TWO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALAN WELCOME.
I WANNA.
AREA TODAY WELL THANKS VERY MUCH
GOOD.
SO WE WILL.
.
PLEASE OPEN WITH YOUR.
SOME.
YOUR OPENING STATEMENT.
THANK VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR.
I'M HERE DAY PRESENT EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY TWO WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO
DIVERSIFY THE FINANCING
PORTFOLIO FOR THE PORT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
INTERNATIONAL TRADE IS A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF OUR
NATION'S ECONOMY AND
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN SERVING OUR NATION ST
NEEDS.
THE FACT MORE THAN FORTY PERCENT
OF THE TOTAL CONTAINERIZED CARGO
ENTERING UNITED STATES ARRIVES
AT CALIFORNIA PORTS. AND ALMOST
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE NATION'S
EXPORTS FLOW THROUGH OUR PORTS
AS WELL.
TRADE IS A MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR R.
CONNIE RELATING TO ALMOST TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT OR ACCORDING TO MRS
OVER TO TWENTY FIVE PERCENT. OF
OUR ECONOMY.
CORD ACTIVITIES EMPLOY MORE THAN
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA THEY ALSO GENERATE
ESTIMATED NINE BILLION DOLLARS
IN STATE AND LOCAL TAX REVENUE
ANNUALLY. ARE IN ADDITION TO
THE.
BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF ALL OF
OUR MONEY THAT'S CREATING JOBS
IN THE LOCAL ECONOMIES. MAIL.
SECOND.
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I NINE SIX TWO IS IS VERY
SIMPLY NEW AND INNOVATIVE WAY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT OUR
NATIONAL TRAIN CONNIE AND MAKE
SURE THAT OUR PORTS REMAIN
COMPETITIVE R. WITH INCREASED
COMPETITION NOT ONLY NATIONALLY
BUT INTERNATIONALLY.
A COMES ON THE HEELS OF AB SIXTY
THREE BY CENTER IS OR HALL IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN OTHER ALSO
CREATED OTHER FOR REPORT
FINANCING OPPORTUNITIES. NINE
SIXTY TWO ACCRETING NEW PUBLIC
FINANCING PROGRAM TO ENCOURAGE
FUTURE INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE I CALIFORNIA
SEAPORTS TO ADMINISTERED BY THE
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE BANK.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
INTRODUCED ANDREW ANGELA FROM
THE CIVIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND THANK YOU SOMEONE
MEMBER ALLEN FOR REVIVING A
PROPOSAL THAT WE FIRST BROUGHT
YOU TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. OF THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION IS THE MAJOR
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THEIR
INTERNATIONAL FIRMS THAT ARE THE
LEAST TENANTS OF THE PUBLIC
PORTS
PUBLIC PORTS OUR STATE ASSETS.
WE AT THE STATE LEVEL HAVE SET
VERY SIGNIFICANT GOALS WITH
RESPECT TO CLEANING GREENING OUR
PORTS OF REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS AND OTHER HARMFUL
POLLUTANTS.
AND IN MANY CASES WE'VE GONE
IT'S A GREAT AMOUNT OF DETAIL
ABOUT THE OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT
TO ACHIEVE.
BUT WE NEED MORE WORK ON EXACTLY
HOW WE WOULD SPUR THE INVESTMENT
AND BE A PARTNER.
IN THE INVESTMENT WITH THE
PRIVATE A POOR TENANTS AND THE
PUBLIC FORCE AS WELL. AND THIS
PROPOSAL IS A WAY IN WHICH THE
STATE CAN PARTNER AND REWARD
PRIVATE PORT TENANTS THAT
ALREADY HAVE EQUIPMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT.
WORKS FINE AND HAS A LONG SHELF
LIFE
BUT. BASED ON THE GOALS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR PLANS.
WOULD BE UPGRADED.
AT GREAT EXPENSE.
ARE WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO MEET
THESE GOALS TO CLEAN AND GREEN
OUR COURTS BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
PRESERVE ECONOMIC
COMPETITIVENESS.
.
PORTS AROUND THE WORLD AROUND
THE COUNTRY ARE PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF INCENTIVE
FUNDS TO GO AFTER THE MUCH
VALUED DISCRETIONARY CARVEL.
A FORTY PERCENT OF THIS NATION'S
CARGO R. GOES THROUGH THE PORTS
OF LOS ANGELES AND LONG BEACH
FOR DESTINATIONS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S PART OF THE
PRIDE FOR THE STATE THAT WE ARE
SUCH A MAGNET FOR ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY BUT. THERE'S NO
GUARANTEE AND WHEN THE
BENEFICIAL CARGO OWNERS ARE
TARGETS THE WALMART THE HOME
DEPOTS OF THE WORLD WHEN THEY
MAKE A LOGISTICS DECISION TO
MOVE THE CAR GO TO ANOTHER STATE
IT DOESN'T COME BACK.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE THINK
THIS IS A WIN WIN.
WHERE WE DEPRIVE REPORT TENANTS
WOULD MAKE AN INVESTMENT TO
FRANKLY UPGRADED EQUIPMENT
BEFORE ITS USEFUL LIFE?
AND HAVE
A PARTNERSHIP IN THE INVESTMENT
WITH THE STATE AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I WOULD LIKE TO JUST
HAVE CLARIFICATION.
MISTER COOLEY MADE THE MOTION.
THERE ARE AMENDMENTS WITH THIS
AND DOES THAT INCLUDE THEM AND.
WE'VE ACCEPTED ALL AMENDMENTS
THANKS VERY MUCH I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY. THANK YOU.
WAY HAVE MOTION AND WE HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION.
QUESTIONS WERE COMMITTEE YES
WITH A MEMORABLE I HAVE I HAVE A
COUPLE OF CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL THAT THE THE FIRST HAS
SIGNED A BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THIS WAS HELD IN APPROACH SAID
AS A RESULT OF THE. ON SOME
FAIRLY SIGNIFICANT COST CONCERNS
AND I HAD AN OLD TO ALL OF YOU
KNOW WE'RE NOT APPROACH SPEER.
AYE I DON'T SEE ANY INDICATION
THAT THOSE HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED.
ON THE SECOND AND PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANT CONCERN THAT I HAVE
IS.
AYE AYE REALLY RESPECT THAT A
PACIFIC MERCHANTS SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECT THE FACT
THAT THEY'RE IN SUPPORT OF THIS.
BUT THIS IS ALSO.
SUPPOSED TO BE BENEFICIAL TO ALL
THE PORTS WHICH AND.
THE AUTHOR STATEMENT ARE ARE A
SET FORTH LONG BEACH LA OAKLAND
PORT HUENEME THE RICHMOND.
AND SAN DIEGO AND WE DON'T HAVE
A SINGLE LETTER OF SUPPORT FROM
A FROM ANY OF THOSE PORTS SO.
I I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
COULD BE WORTH THE.
.
WITH THIS BILL SO IT.
UNLESS THERE'S A SATISFACTORY
ANSWER FOR THAT I'M NOT PREPARED
TO.
DEVOTED THE.
MAYBE FOR A QUESTION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
WE THOUGHT THE BILL IN ITS
ORIGINAL FORM REALLY HAS CHECKS
AND BALANCES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
IN THIS VERSION THE BILL.
MEETING AFTER REPORT SUBMITS AN
APPLICATION TO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BANK CARDS AS
OWN INDEPENDENT CONSULTANT TO AN
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT TO PROJECTED
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY MEETING SALES
TAX REVENUE AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL. IS VERIFIED AND
LEGITIMATE AND EVEN AFTER THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TO TAKE A
SECONDARY ACT TO APPROPRIATE THE
FUNDS
SO THERE ARE CHECKS AND BALANCES
AND VERIFICATION. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THIS INVESTMENT
IS GOING TO HAVE ONE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS THAT'S
BUILT INTO WHAT THE BILL BILL
AUTHORIZES BUT THEN THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF THE STATE.
NOTHING HAPPENS UNTIL THE
LEGISLATURE MAKES THE FINAL THEY
STILL CONTROL THE POWER THE
PERKS THEY MAKE THE FINAL
DECISION.
ON WHETHER NOT APPROPRIATION IS
LEGITIMATE EVEN AFTER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK AND THE
PUBLIC POOR HAS APPROVED.
AS FAR AS I THE TIMING OF
LETTERS OF SUPPORT YOU KNOW FROM
OTHER PORTS I THINK YOU KNOW IF
THE BILL'S ALLOWED TO MOVE
FORWARD.
AND STANFORD AND HOPEFULLY WE
GET FURTHER THAN APPROPRIATIONS
THIS TIME.
WE ANTICIPATE THAT AS MORE PRO
SPORTS BECOME AWARE THEY WILL BE
IN SUPPORT AND I WILL MENTION
THAT.
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTS TERMINAL
OPERATORS ALSO TO THE COASTLINE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES.
I MEAN I I I APPRECIATE THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE STRUCTURE THE
BILL AND HOW IT WORKS AND.
IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD I
THINK ASSUME THEIR PROPS
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WILL
TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT IT TO FROM
THAT FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE.
I.
THE THE BILL WAS SO FIRST HER
BACK IN TWENTY SIXTEEN.
SO AGAIN OF.
THAT'S PRETTY LONG PERIOD OF
TIME.
FOR WHICH TOOK AGAINST PORT TO
AND.
EITHER LETTERS OF EXPRESSION OF
INTEREST OR OPPOSITION OR
SUPPORT FROM A. UP FROM ALL THE
SAID VERY SPORTS IN THE CITY AND
AND OTHER INTERESTS AND SEEING
NO SUPPORT AT ALL HERE EXCEPT
FOR.
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION GIVES ME. ON SOME
LEVEL OF CONCERN.
MAY YET BE SOMETHING BECAUSE
THEY SHOULD MOVE FORWARD BUT I'D
LIKE THERE TO BE A TO SEE MORE
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT ON.
THANK YOU ON ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
YES AT A.
ASSEMBLY RECOVERY ARROW. I HAVE
A.
A FEW QUESTIONS.
IN NIGHT IT YOU MAY ACTUALLY
HAVE ANSWERED THE QUESTION.
IN REGARDS TO THAT THAT TO.
ECONOMIC IMPACT REPORTS THAT.
ANTICIPATED IN HERE.
I WAS IN I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COST UP THE FIRST IT'S THE
IT'S THE THEIR REPORT. IT SOUNDS
LIKE IT'S IT'S THE REPORT THAT'S
COMMISSIONED BY THE PORT
AUTHORITY AND THEN THE SECOND
ONE WOULD BE COMMISSIONED BY THE
AYE BANK SCRATCH AT THE PENTAGON
ASSEMBLYMEMBER. OKAY.
AND AND I AM AND I'M RIGHT ANY
OTHER MEAN TO GET TECHNICAL BUT
HAVING WORKED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION SOME OF THE
WORDING BECOMES IMPORTANT
BECAUSE IN YOU GOTTA FOLLOW THE
WORDING THAT THE LETTER OF THE
LAW AND.
AND MY CONCERN WAS PEER
REVIEWED IN AND.
PEER REVIEWED BECAUSE PARA VIEW
ANTICIPATES IN SENATOR
SCIENTIFIC COMMUNITY AND THAT'S
DIFFERENT THAN JUST HAVING
ANOTHER ECONOMIST FOR EXAMPLE
LOOKING AT.
AT AT THE REPORT IN ANALYZING IT
AND AND GIVING THEIR OWN
OPINIONS SO I'M I'M A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THE OTHER
QUESTION I HAD. SO I WAS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE COST OF
THAT.
THE.
.
THE BILL SAYS THAT THE HARBOR
AGENCY WILL. ON.
AB REIMBURSE THE AYE BANK FOR.
THEY'RE IN ADMINISTRATIVE
EXPENSES AND USUALLY ONE HAVE A
MAXIMUM SO THAT. THE IBM CAN SEE
BY THE WAY THIRTY PERCENT OR YOU
KNOW A NUMBER THAT'S REALLY
HIGH.
I WOULD RECOMMEND SOME NUMBER
THAT'S AN ADMINISTRATIVE NUMBER
THAT MAKE SENSE BY A AYE AYE M..
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE AYE BANK
USES AS THE RULE OF THUMB BUT IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO KNOW THAT AND
THEN THE OTHER ISSUE I HAD ON.
WHICH.
UP YOU KNOW KIND OF THE DEVIL'S
IN THE DETAILS IS THE ISSUE
RELATED TO PURCHASING EQUIPMENT.
FOR A PRIVATE PARTY.
THAT IT THEN OWNS AND OPERATES
THAT EQUIPMENT.
THAT THEN BECOMES OF THE
PROPERTY OF THE STATE WHEN
THEY'RE DONE WITH IT AND.
IT AND I GUESS THE CONCERN
ABOUT IT IS A BIT IF IF IT'S
PAID.
IF THERE'S PROPERTY THAT'S PESO
BUT LIKE RENTING RENTERS DON'T
TAKE VERY GOOD CARE OF THE
PLACES THEY RENTED A GENERAL.
IF THEY TAKE A LOT MORE CARE OF
IT IF IT'S THEIR OWN IF THEY
PAID THEIR OWN MONEY FOR IT SO
I'M CONCERNED WITH WITH USING
THAT PUBLIC RESOURCES TO THEN.
GET EQUIPMENT.
AND THAT.
THE WET WITH OUT THERE BEING A
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY MAINTAIN
IT AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL SO THAT
IT REALLY HAS MAINTAINED ITS
VALUE AND IT'S GOT SOME.
.
SO IT'S SO THAT IS PROTECTED
AGAINST IT SO THE ACID IS
PROTECTED
AND.
.
SO I WAS CONCERNED ABOUT THAT AS
WELL AND THAT'S OBVIOUS
SOMETHING YOU PUT IN A CONTRACT
BUT I WOULD WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S.
THAT THE INVESTMENT IN STATE.
WHEN IF YOU'RE USING STATE FUNDS
THAT YOU'RE PROTECTING THAT
INVESTMENT.
SO CHAIR.
THANK YOU SO IN EVERY QUESTIONS
ON YOUR FIRST QUESTION ABOUT THE
COST YOU KNOW THERE'S A TENSION.
IN THE DESIGN OF THE BILL
BETWEEN HAVING INFRASTRUCTURE
BANKS COME COSTS BE REIMBURSED
BY THE PORCH BUT THEN WITH WITH
A CAP ON THAT THEN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK HAS COSTS
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BE PAID FOR.
BY THE GENERAL FUND AND SO WE
DESIGNED THE BILL SO THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BANK IN REVIEWING
THE APPLICATIONS THAT ARE
INITIATED BY THE COURTS. WOULD
BE ABLE TO THEN SUBMIT THEIR
COST TO THE PORCH WHO ARE
SEEKING APPROVAL FROM THE STATE.
FOR THIS KIND OF THE FINANCING
ARRANGEMENT.
BUT WE'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU
AND YOUR STAFF TO COME UP WITH
SOME BETTER RIGHT DESIGNS ON
THAT BUT THAT WAS KIND OF OUR
BEST APPROACH TO. ADDRESS THE
COST ISSUE.
AND THEN SECONDLY WHAT'S. SO IF
I COULD ON THE INVESTMENT BANK
UP THEY DON'T USE THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T GET INFUSIONS OF
GENERAL FUND HAVE IT THEY'VE
THERE THEY HAVE A REVOLVING
ACCOUNT THAT THEY USE RIGHT AND
SO.
WEREN'T.
IT'S NOT ANTICIPATE IN OTHER
WORDS THE MONEY WOULD HAVE TO
COME OUT OF THIS. GRANT BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO TO
IDENTIFY FROM THEIR PERSPECTIVE
HOW MUCH DOES IT COST YOU TO DO
IT ALONE.
BECAUSE.
EITHER DON'T GET IT BACK IN THE
LOAN PROCESS USUALLY AND IF THIS
IS THE GRANT. PROGRAM THEN THEY
DON'T GET IT BACK IN THE LOAN
IT'S A GRANT AND THEN WE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COST IS. AND
GENERALLY SPEAKING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS USUALLY END
IN BILLS ARE ANYWHERE FROM. MEET
THEY'RE USUALLY NOT MORE THAN
FIFTEEN PERCENT SO I WOULD FEEL
MORE COMFORTABLE IN THIS KIND OF
A PROCESS HAVING A NUMBER. AND
YOU AND I WOULD ADVISE WORKING
WITH THE I. BANK BECAUSE THEY'LL
HAVE THAT NUMBER IN TERMS OF
HOW.
WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE LOAN THE
END UP?
EITHER HOLDING BACK OR USING AS
RESOURCES TO PAY THEMSELVES SO.
SO.
TYPOGRAPHY READING AND HEARING
THE AUTHOR.
IMMIGRANT GOOD POINTS ABOUT
HAVING SOME GUIDELINES YOU KNOW
FOR LIMITATIONS ON
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THE POINT
OF THIS BILL AND WE DIDN'T BRING
IDEA FOR IT IN. TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN ARE NOW TO HAVE YOU KNOW
TOO MANY RESOURCES GOAL TORIES
OVERHEAD WE WANT. THIS TO BE A
FINANCING PROGRAM TO GET GREENER
CLEAR PROJECTS AT PORTSMOUTH
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT WHICH IS IN
KEEPING WITH THE STATE'S GOALS.
IN A SUSTAINABLE AFRAID ACTION
PLAN AN EXECUTIVE ORDER ISSUED
BY THE GOVERNOR.
SO WE WOULD VERY MUCH WORK WITH
YOU TO TAKE YOUR ADVICE AND TRY
TO GET SOME FEEDBACK.
FROM THE INFRASTRUCTURE BANK ON
EXACTLY HOW THE DESIGN THAT WILL
WOULD BE AN ACCEPTABLE.
LIMITATION ON WITH RESPECT TO
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ON THAT.
VERY HAPPY TO DO THAT THE NINETY
SECOND POINT ABOUT.
THE.
MAINTENANCE OF THE EQUIPMENT
OVER TIME.
THE PORT SIR PUBLIC ASSETS OF
THE STATE THE PUBLIC PORTS IN A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OWN OPERATE
THESE. ASSETS BASICALLY ENTRUST.
THE TIDE LINES ACT WOULD STAY
TO CALIFORNIA AND THEY SET
STANDARDS FOR. THE MEMBER
COMPANIES OF PMSA WHO ARE THE
ACTUAL TERMINAL OPERATORS.
ON MANY MANY THINGS INCLUDING.
GOOD WORKING ORDER OF THE
EQUIPMENT BUT ALSO ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT OF THAT EQUIPMENT.
AND WHAT THIS BILL IS FOCUSED ON
IS TRYING TO GET THE PORCH TO
INVEST EARLIER THAN THEY MAY
HAVE OTHERWISE WOULD TO BUY
CLEANER GREENER ZERO MISSIONS
EQUIPMENT.
SOONER THEN THE OTHER WOULD
BASED ON THE USEFUL LIFE OF
WHAT'S CURRENTLY ON THE PART
PROPERTY NOW.
AND THESE ARE THE INCENTIVES OF
WE SAT THROUGH LEGISLATION TO
REGULATORY GOALS AND PUBLIC
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN INVESTED IN
FORKS AND IMPORTANT WITH MEN.
FROM.
THIS SOURCE THAT WE'RE
PROPOSING FROM GIGI R. F.
DOLLARS
FROM CARL MOYER FUNDS THAT ARE
DISPUTED BY THE AIR DISTRICTS
AND MANY OTHER SOURCES TO SO
THERE'S. A LOT OF PRECEDENT FOR
HAVING THE PUBLIC INCENTIVIZE
AND HARDER INVESTING IN CLEANER
EQUIPMENT COURTS.
THREE GOOD. MEN IN THEM ONE LAST
ISSUE THAT IN TERMS OF THE LAND
COMMISSION.
IT THAT THEY CAN OBJECT AND
THAT CATCH THINKS THE WHOLE DEAL
AND I WAS WONDERING IF THERE'S A
WAY TO DO THAT FIRST.
ARE YOU ANTICIPATING THEM
LOOKING AT THE ECONOMIC.
BUT REPORT AS WELL OR IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT THAT. IF YOU'RE
IF YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A KILL
SWITCH.
THE EARLIER IT IS BEFORE YOU
SPEND MONEY THE BETTER.
AND.
AND THAT IT SEEMS TO ME THAT
THE STATE LANDS IS THE KILL
SWITCH.
THEY ARE THE KILL SWITCH IN THE
END OF THE PORCH BASICALLY HAVE
SUBORDINATE A DELEGATED
AUTHORITY FROM THE LAST MISSION.
AND SO.
WE DIDN'T FORMALLY RIGHT A ROLE
ON THE FRONT END BECAUSE WE
THINK THE LAST COMMISSION
TYPICALLY THE ROLE THEY PLAY IS
TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT.
IT'S AN APPROPRIATE USE OF THE
LAND AND FOR ANY TERMINAL OR ANY
ACTIVITY ON TIGHTLY AS PROPERTY.
MAINTAINED LOCALLY THEY HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS TODAY.
WE'VE SEEN BILLS IN THIS
COMMITTEE ON THIS QUESTION
BEFORE. AND SO.
WE'VE EITHER THAT PROCESS WOULD
WORK WITH IF THERE'S A FURTHER
CONCERN WE CAN TRY AND ADDRESS
THAT.
BUT I THINK WE HAVE THE
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS DONE INITIALLY
BY THE PORT AS AN AGENT OF THE
STATE.
THROUGH THE THAILAND'S ACT
AND HAVE THEM THERE HAS TO BE
VERIFIED BY INDEPENDENT
CONSULTANT THAT'S NOT ON THE
PAYROLL OF.
THE TERMINAL OPERATOR OR THE
POOR TO DETERMINES THE NUMBERS
ARE CORRECT IN THE GULF THEIR.
OKAY AYE AYE I NEED TO THINK
THROUGH THAT WHOLE DELEGATED
AUTHORITY BECAUSE IT IT SEEMS TO
ME IF IT'S DELEGATED AUTHORITY
UNLESS IT'S AN ABUSE OF
DISCRETION THEY CAN'T. BE THE
KILL SWITCH.
BECAUSE THEY DELEGATED SO I AM I
AM ANYTHING ABOUT AND I JUST I'M
JUST TRYING TO FIGURE OUT IT.
A WAY TO BE ABLE TO.
THERE IS A SECTION A BILL THAT
SAYS LAWRENCE COMMISSION WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT YET AND
THAT IS WHAT THAT'S WHAT I SAW
AND IT IT JUST SEEMS TO ME.
AFTER YOU'VE HIRED THE ECONOMIST
AND GONE THROUGH THIS WHOLE
PROCESS.
.
IF YOU EAT YOU IF YOU JUST TAKE
TO THEN HAVE.
.
HAVING THE RUG PULLED OUT FROM
UNDER WHEN THERE'S BEEN THIS YOU
KNOW LIKE PATHWAY LET.
I THINK THEY MAY BE THAT ARE YOU
KNOW YOU KNOW I INTERNET SAYING
YEAH I'M IN THAT THERE'S SO MUCH
BUREAUCRACY SOMETIMES DRIVES ME
CRAZY AND I KNOW THAT'S WHAT I'M
LOOKING AT IT TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW DO YOU. HOW DO YOU BE A
HOW DO YOU WORK IN PARTNERSHIP
IN THE I GUESS MAYBE THAT'S THE
ANSWER I I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND A
QUESTION I THINK YOU KNOW CHIT
TO KINDA REFOCUS WHAT THE BILL
DOES? THE BILL CREATES A NEW
FINANCING.
RIGHT FACILITY FOR PORTS IN
THIS IS FOR YOU TO A LOT OF
PORTS WILL HAVE OLDER EQUIPMENT
THAT HAS YOU KNOW MANY YEARS
MILLION DECADES OF SERVICE LIFE
LEFT ON IT BUT MAYBE IT'S DIESEL
EQUIPMENT RIGHT ANY ACCORDING
TO OUR NEW MISSIONS MANDATES AND
HER SCHOOLS STATES THAT YOU KNOW
MAYBE ONE AGREED OUR PORTS MAYBE
THEY WANT TO BUY SOME NEW WERE.
YOU MORE FISHING EQUIPMENT THAT
IS ZERO EMISSIONS ETCETERA. THIS
GIVES THE OPERATOR THE ABILITY
TO PARTNER WITH THE STATE TO
PURCHASE EQUIPMENT.
BOB OBVIOUSLY THEY WILL BE THE
ONES BEARING THE COST AND IT'S
REALLY INCUMBENT UPON THEM TO
MAKE THE CASE TO GET THE
FACILITY THAT WHEN YOUR TIME OF
THE KILL SWITCH THE STATE LANDS.
I THINK STATE LANDS WANTS TO BE
KIND OF A IN THE LAST IN THE
LINE THEY DON'T HAVE TO LOOK AT
IN THE BEGINNING WHEN IT'S NOT
REALLY CqC TO WHO THEY WANT
SICK AGAIN BRING US THE WHOLE
DEAL BEFORE IT'S ALL THAT WE IN
WHEN IT'S ALL DONE. AND WRAPPED
UP.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO.
EXCEPT THIS OR OR DENY THIS WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT SIMPLY
GIVES US THE ABILITY TO DO A NEW
FACILITY. SO IT GIVES OUR PORTS
THE ABILITY TO STAY COMPETITIVE
WITH ALL THE OTHER PORTS ARE
COMPETING FOR BUSINESS NOW
WHETHER THAT OF MEXICO OR. YOU
UP UP IN THE NORTHERN STATES TO
US OR EVEN ON YOU KNOW THAT THE
TEXAS COAST AROUND ARE ON THE
EAST COAST. IT AND THAT REALLY
IS THE KEY IS THAT OUR COURTS
ARE FALLING BEHIND IN BUSINESSES
GOING ELSEWHERE AND SO CENTER IS
OR HALL BACK IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SAW THIS AND SAID LOOK YOU KNOW
OUR PORTS NEED EXTRA. RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO STAY COMPETITIVE
ANSWER HE HAD DONE A BILL THIS
ACTUALLY FURTHERS THAT IT
CREATES A NEW FACILITY. AND AND
IT DOESN'T YOU'D MENTION A
COUPLE OF GREAT POINTS ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE COSTS INVOLVED IN HOW
WHICH WOULD BE ADMINISTRATIVE
COST BE IT CETERA. ALL OF THESE
WOULD BE AGREED UPON BY THE
ACTUAL POOR OPERATORS AND THE
PORTS THEMSELVES PRIOR TO THE
DEALS GOING THROUGH SO I I
ACTUALLY SHARE YOUR CONCERN OF
YOU KNOW BUREAUCRATIC RED TAPE.
AND COST ULTIMATELY TO THE PORTS
BUT YOU KNOW THIS WOULD BE THE
OPENING THAT THE LANE IF YOU
WILL AND THEN IT WOULD BE UP TO
THE PORCH DECIDE AND POOR
OPERATORS YES WE DO WANT TO. YOU
KNOW TRY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE THIS
FACILITY TO GET THIS DEAL DONE
AND SO THEY WOULD BASICALLY MAKE
SURE THAT THE DEAL WAS
ACCEPTABLE FOR THEM. BEFORE IT
AS THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT WAS
BROUGHT THROUGH THE STATE
AGENCIES AND THEN OF COURSE THE
STATE STILL HAS THE ABILITY WITH
THE STATE LANDS AND AND THE
OTHER IDENTITIES. TO SHUT YOU
KNOW ANY OF THESE DEALS NOW THEY
DIDN'T LIKE THE DEALS BUT IT
OPENS UP A LANE THAT DOESN'T
EXIST RIGHT NOW.
AND WE TAKE A LOOK AT AYE SO MY
DISTRICT I HAVE.
ALL OR PARTS ABOUT THIRTEEN
CITIES INCORPORATING OF
INCORPORATING ORANGE COUNTY BUT
I ENDED THE ARM LA LINE SO I GO
RIGHT UP TO THE LONG BEACH LINE.
AND WE HAVE UNIT THE TO THOUGH
THE LARGE SPORTS IN THE COUNTRY
LEN LONG BEACH RIGHT THERE. AND
SO THOSE ARE RIGHT OUTSIDE MY
DISTRICT A LOT OF SUPPORT
WORKERS LIVE RIGHT IN MY
DISTRICT.
AND YOU KNOW WITH THE NUMBERS WE
STARTED WE STAYED IN THE
BEGINNING ABOUT FORTY PERCENT OF
THE CONTAINERIZED CARGO GOING
THROUGH OUR PORTS.
THIS IS A VERY VERY BIG DEAL
AND HUGE CONTRIBUTE NOT STATE TO
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY IN MY DISTRICT
BUT TO THE ENTIRE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE IS
ONE WHICH WE PRESERVE THIS
BUSINESS FORCE YOU TO CALIFORNIA
LAWMAKERS GOOD YOU'LL FOR THE
PORT OPERATORS FOR THE PORTS.
AND FOR THE STATE ALL THE SAME
TIME BUT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
YOU KNOW GIVE THESE PORTS
AIRPORT OPERATORS THE ABILITY TO
UPGRADE THEIR EQUIPMENT. TO MAKE
THEMSELVES MORE EFFICIENT MORE
GREEN TO KEEP UP WITH ALL THE
NEW STATE REGULATIONS BUT ALSO.
TO HAVE THE BEST PORT
FACILITIES THAT CAN OFFER THE
BEST EXPERIENCE TO THEIR END
USERS THEIR CLIENTS SO WE CAN
KEEP THIS BUSINESS FLOWING
THROUGH CALIFORNIA FOR A WHOLE
ECONOMY. IT'S I I TOTALLY AGREE
WITH EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING
AND I THINK THAT PMSA IS MORE
THAN WILLING TO SIT OUT AS AM I.
IT ANYTHING YOU WANT TO TAKE A
LOOK AT.
TO MAKE SURE THERE'S A FAIR
PROCESS FOR THE POOR OPERATORS
AND FOR THE STATE I THINK WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF THAT WORK YOU KNOW
AS WE'VE GONE THROUGH HIS.
THIS BILL IS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR QUITE SOMETIME NOW.
ARE BUT I I ACTUALLY WELCOME
THAT AND IF USUALLY RIGHT IN
THAT TO.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOMS POINT
ABOUT THE LETTERS OF SUPPORT OF
VARIOUS PORTS.
WE WE HAVE WORKED WITH PMSA UP
PRINCIPALLY ON THIS BECAUSE THEY
DO HAVE ON PORT OPERATIONS AT
THE VARIOUS PORTS IT'S A THEY
ACTUALLY REPRESENT THE END USERS
THAT ARE YOU USING THESE. BUT AS
THIS BILL KIND OF GETS MORE LEGS
UNDERNEATH IT THAT'S GOTTEN THAT
WAS WHAT WE WERE KIND OF WAITING
FOR BEFORE YOU'RE ENGAGING THE
POTS BUT IT IS AN EXCELLENT
POINT SOMEWHER BLOOM AND I
THINK THAT ALL OF THE PORTS. AYE
IT LEASE ALL OF ONE'S LIFE IT
INFORMAL CONVERSATIONS WITH I'M
I'M GUESSING AND YOU DON'T SPEAK
THIS ARE IN FAVOR OF THIS AS
WELL BECAUSE IT JUST CREATES YOU
KNOW AN ABILITY FOR US TO
INCREASE OUR INVESTMENT. INTO
OUR PORTS WHICH MAKES THEM MORE
COMPETITIVE AVE DOES IT TIE
ANYBODY'S HANDS IT JUST GIVES
THEM ANOTHER TOOL THESE.
PRECIADO THINKS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE.
YES.
OF SOMERVELL PELVIC.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND HERE'S THE REASON.
WE'VE.
BEN IN A RECOVERY FOR NINE
YEARS.
TIMES HAVE BEEN GOOD.
OUR BUDGET LOOKS GOOD.
SUPPOSEDLY.
THEN I DON'T USE THAT WORD
POLITICALLY.
SUPPOSEDLY WE OF A NINE TEAM
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS RIGHT NOW IN THE BANK.
AND THE REASON I USETHE WORD
SUPPOSEDLY IS NOT YOU GOTTA
COUNTED UP. DON'T KNOW COULD BE
A LITTLE BIT OFF.
DON'T KNOW.
WE WILL HAVE A RECESSION.
NO DOUBT.
ALWAYS COMES.
AND THIS NEXT RECESSION MAY BE
VERY STRANGE.
BECAUSE OF THEIR POLITICAL
SITUATION OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
DON'T KNOW.
SO I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE.
IN MY MILITARY EXPERIENCE.
WHEN NO ONE'S.
SHOOTING AT YOU YOU DIG DEEPER.
YOU PILE UP MORE AMMO.
I PUT MORE.
CHAO WITH.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
OKAY IF I GOT IT.
SO.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE WE
SHOULD REINFORCE OUR PORT
SYSTEM.
BEFORE EVERYTHING GETS SOME
REALLY WEIRD IN THIS COUNTRY.
.
THAT WAY WE CAN SUPPORT A HIGHER
LEVEL.
OF IMPORTS AND EXPORTS.
THEN OTHER COUNTRIES BECAUSE.
THE NEXT RECESSION BECOMES WILL
BE WORLD WIDE.
AND CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO COMPETE.
BOTTOM. AND THE TOP.
SO I THINK THIS THING.
PRETTY DARN GOOD.
AND MY LAST WORDS ARE.
LET'S HOPE THE BIG RECESSION TAX
INCOME BUT WE GOTTA BE READY.
MA'AM.
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FOR COMMITTEE.
SINGER WHICH I TO CLOSE SOME
REMEMBER ABSOLUTELY A IN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SO VERY VOCAL YEAH
I THINK IT DIDN'T REALLY WHAT
THIS RELATES IS MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PORTS ARE ASKING HAD OF THIS
POSSIBLE. AND I THINK THE SIMPLY
MEMBERS POINT.
THIS IS YOU KNOW THIS JUST
CREATES THE FACILITY THIS WE
BACKED UP BY THE PORT OPERATORS
AND AND THAT THE PAYEES. ARE WHO
HAVE AN EXCELLENT TRACK RECORD
OF MAKING SURE THAT ALL OF THEIR
PAYMENTS ARE MADE. OF IT OF
COURSE THE STATE HAS COMPLETE
DISCRETION ON HOW YOU KNOW HOW
THIS FACILITIES USE BUT IT JUST
CREATES AN AVENUE WHERE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE OUR PORTS TO
MAKE THE NECESSARY
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. YOU
REST ASSURED OTHER STATES ARE
DOING THE SAME THING AND OTHER
ECONOMIES IT YEAH OTHER NATIONS
ARE DOING THE SAME THING TO
DIRECTLY COMPETE WITH CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE BUSINESS AWAY FROM OUR
PORTS. SENATOR THEIR PORS TAKE
OUR JOBS FROM FROM OUR PORTS AND
SEND IT OVER THERE IT WHETHER
IT'S NORTH OR SOUTH OR EAST OF
US.
THIS JUST MAKES SENSE.
IT MAKES SENSE FOR ALL OF OUR
PORTS IT MAKES SENSE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA FOR JOBS FOR MAKING
SURE THERE ARE CONNIE STRONG AND
VIBRANT AND THAT WE GET TO USE
OUR GEOGRAPHIC RESOURCES. OF
HAVING THESE INCREDIBLE PORTS
WHICH WE BUILT UP FOR DECADES AT
ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN THAT WORK
THERE. AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY
REMAIN VIABLE AN EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE NOT JUST NOW BUT
INTO THE FUTURE AND AT THE SAME
TIME ARE ARE ALSO AMONG THE MOST
EFFICIENT. THE GREENEST IN THE
LOWEST EMISSIONS ARE IN THE
ENTIRE NATION
AND IS THE VERY LAST POINT ALL
BRING UP.
YOU KNOW I'M A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GUY BORN AND RAISED
I'VE LIVED IN HIKES BEACH FOR
LAST COUPLE DECADES. AND I'VE
SAT HERE THE LEGISLATURE LAST
SIX YEARS AND A LOT OF WHAT WE
GET YOUR ABOUT BOBBY SEES AIR
POLLUTION RIGHT AND WE'RE ALL
VERY SENSITIVE TO. THE FACT THAT
MANY PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA LIVING
AREAS WITH VERY BAD AIR QUALITY.
AND AS WE KNOW THIS TYPICALLY
CENTERS AROUND YOU KNOW.
HUBS OF ACTIVITY SUCH AS PORT
SUCH AS FREEWAYS IVES'S LOT OF
ACTIVITY GOING BACK AND FORTH
THE MORE MONEY THAT WE CAN
INVEST INTO OUR PORTS THE
GREATER THEY CAN BECOME THE LESS
EMISSIONS WILL BE PRODUCING.
WHICH MEANS A BETTER AIR QUALITY
FOR EVERYBODY LIVES AROUND THERE
THE BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE IS
NOT JUST ABOUT YOU KNOW PEOPLE
GETTING THEIR JOBS IN OUR
ECONOMY DOING GREAT WHICH OF
COURSE BENEFITS ALL OF US. THIS
IS ALSO ABOUT IMPROVING THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WHICH ALL
CALIFORNIANS LIVE ESPECIALLY
THOSE PEOPLE LIVE NEAR PORTS
BECAUSE IS DIRECTLY.
PEOPLE WILL BE IMPACTED IN A
VERY FAVORABLE WAY.
SO I THINK IT'S IT'S A WIN WIN
WIN FOR THE STATE IT'S A WIN FOR
YOU KNOW ALL OF OUR PORTS IN THE
PORT WORKERS AND COMPANIES IN
BUSINESS THERE.
BUT IT'S ALSO WIN FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT YOU KNOW LIVE IN THE
VICINITY AND WILL BE THE
BENEFICIARIES OF AN IMPROVED
ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE WE'VE
APPROVE THIS BILL TODAY. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
.
THE CHAIR RECOMMENDATIONS DO
PASSES MENDED OF WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
STICKS HUGE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
A MOTION AS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS ADWARE CURRY AYE.
ADWARE CURRY AYE WALDRON WALDRON
AYE BLOOM.
CUBBY ARROW.
COVER YOUR AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE LACKEY. LACKEY AYE
VOTE HOW AFFIRMATIVE.
PROPEL AYE.
BILLS OUT EIGHT ZERO AND I'M
ASKING IF THE COMMITTEE COULD
JUST HOLD ON FOR A COUPLE
MINUTES BEFORE THE. THE END
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY MUCH.
SO WE HAVE ONE BELONG CALL.
AND THAT IS AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR.
CURRENT VOTE IS FOR TO TO.
COVER GYRO. EDUARDO GARCIA.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE VOTE PELL.
NEGATIVE
VOTE HELL NO.
BILL IS NOT FIVE THREE.
SO EDUARDO WE HAVE FUN.
NONE.
IS TO US OKAY GOOD. ALRIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE IN
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED